um good evening to members
officers members of the public and
press if we have anyone with us tonight
welcome to this planning meeting
of the 23rd of june
as always a little bit of housekeeping
uh we're back
in our own home now as we call it um if
the firearm
is activated please vacate the offices
via the stairs
either through the security door which
is to
my right but to your left
and do not use the lifts in the foyer
please assemble in hawley square
opposite the offices
and an officer will assist you and
advise you when it is deemed to be safe
to return to this chamber
does anybody intend to film the meeting
will they please show their hands
no thank you very much um
moving on restrictions on mobile phones
with everybody present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone calls in the chamber while this
meeting is in progress
this evening i have requests for
speaking
under council procedure 20.1
councillors breedwood gregory
farance and boyd speaking on item
four which is the land of north west of
and southeast sides of shotenden road
if there's any member not on the
committee who wishes to speak
under 20.1 could they please say so
thank you very much
public speaking the foreign applications
have been reserved for public speaking
would members please strike through
following the items on the agenda
agenda item 5a a01
3 the knot agenda
item 5f d06
land rear of 4 to 10 station road
which is in birchington
uh thank you for that members um i'd
like to head over to mrs slimmerson who
has a point of information
thank you chair and good evening uh
point of information for members
on agenda item for the shondane road
application this evening
after the date of the previous planning
committee on the 21st of april 2021
the council received a freedom
information request asking for
information on any agreements held by
the council
relating to the historic sale of any
part of the site which is the subject of
the application
this search has shown that family
district council previously owned the
northern parcel of land
to the north of shondane road and
agreement for the sale of this land in
1982
including the overage clause meaning
that if the land is used for any other
purpose then agriculture
the owner is liable to pay the council
50 of the change in value
as members of the planning committee are
aware covenants or ownership matters are
not material planning considerations
and therefore this historic agreement
cannot be taken into account by members
in making either determination as to
whether or not the planning application
is acceptable when judged against
local and national planning policy as an
additional point
um for information for members of the
public
the process and procedure of planning
committee meetings including the format
of the meeting
and the order of public speaking is
outlined within part
five of the council's constitution
entitled codes and protocols
the relevant section is the protocol for
guidance of planning party members and
officers
and this is available on the council's
website thank you chair
thank you very much ian agenda item one
apologies for
absence i have received apologies from
councillor
alban who has been substituted by
councillor
whitehead also councillor scott
who's substituted by councillor fellows
are there any other policies
thank you i members some two
declarations of interest does anybody
having
any interest at all
hands in the air no okay thank you
agenda item three minutes of the
planning committee meeting held on 19th
of
may 2021 do members agree
that the minutes of the planning
committee meeting held on the 19th of
may 2021
be approved and signed by myself
as chair could i have a proposal please
thank you councillor hart
i do apologize it is difficult to see
people with
masks on so hence i've
got mine down here at the moment thank
you council heart could i have a second
to please
councillor paul moore thank you
councilmoor
do you all agree uh thank you members
agenda item 4 is the planned application
the land on the north west and south
east sides of
shotendome road speaking under council
procedure
20.1 could i ask councillor
braywood is there i thought so thank you
councillor braywood
uh you have three minutes thank you
thank you i must admit chair that i find
er livingston's comments regarding the
15
affordable housing in which he described
as fair and
insults his committee and actually
insults his counsel
as members of this committee will be
well aware last july this council
adopted something called a local plan
this local plan was independently signed
off and deemed
sound page 59 of the local plan states
and i quote
that an area of more than a thousand
square meters shall be required to
provide
30 of the dwellings as affordable
housing i'll read that again
that an area of more than a thousand
square meters shall be provided shall be
required to provide
30 of the dwellings as affordable
housing
we're told that if the development was
to be increased to 30
then then the development would be in a
deficit remember
gradmans are a land promoter and not a
land developer
the lower the affordable housing
percentage the higher the land cost
wizard council cannot bend the rules to
suit certain developers
we have a local plan which developers
will be well aware of
if they cannot meet the requirements
then don't buy the land
simple i asked this committee to show
courage
show bravery and to show respect to your
constituents that elected you
show them that we welcome development in
thanet of course we do
but only when the local plan has been
adhered to this application should not
be deferred for a second time
and the developers should not be given a
third chance this should be rejected due
to the sp
23 not being achieved and if this
application is rejected and it goes to a
pill in so be it
if there's a cost to the council in so
beer
this council has thrown away money from
day dot and continue to throw away money
in the future
but some decisions are worth spending
the money on and if i may share i just
want to quickly draw a reference to the
kcc officers report
that we heard at the last last committee
meeting he assured us that an extra 450
houses at shotandain road
will have no impact on thanic rides
whatsoever because uh
drivers will simply stagger their
journey times so my question is
should any of the 450 households have
school children
can the officer guarantee the child's
safety staying at school until midnight
waiting to be picked
up in which in turn allows the rose to
be less busy than at that time of night
thank you uh thank you councillor
raywood uh
also speaking as uh this time i was walk
counsellor councillor gregory
the position is that the land promoters
governments wanted a hefty reduction in
the number of affordable housing
from 30 to 10 percent they do this to
make more of a profit
when they sell the site with planning
permission to developers
in an area of great deprivation poor
housing and homelessness such as than it
no reduction should be
acceptable moreover affordable housing
in these developments
often reflows to blocks of flats
the on costs of these flats is
staggering with ground rent
sometimes up to four thousand a year
making a mockery of affordable
the local plan says outside of their
urban areas
much of this land is high quality
intensively farmed agriculture land
and refers to the some areas which are
at risk of from flooding
and to contemplate building on land with
a known flood risk as demonstrated
all too well in the past week with the
deluges
will render any homes built on farmland
completely
unaffordable unsellable and uninsurable
insurance exclusions and insurance
successes are a great concern
and examples exist where poor planning
decisions
have impacted on homeowners who have had
to live
with the consequences of an unsalable
home in a flood risk area
concrete cannot observe absorb excess
water
the existing fields mitigate much of the
risk
that the flooding will become
unmanageable if this land is concreted
over
the water will cascade down while it
renders the homes uninhabitable
water then makes its way onto tivoli
brook
it will take rain water from hard
surfaces
and general household surface waste this
water
may well contain chemicals nitrates and
other pollutants
to end up in margate main sands via this
outlet it's named tivoli brook
and it is a watercourse with the new
builds concentrated
over farmland the flooding cannot be
mitigated
this pollution will have a disastrous
effect on the economy
if the beach is out of use visitors will
go
out elsewhere and plan its reputation
will go with it
tdc cannot sacrifice the town's economy
in this way
no development would be worth that the
flood risks cannot be addressed at a
later stage after these houses are built
they this will be irreversible flooding
is a
real threat to existing and potential
homes
i would refer the committee to the
decisions made by
dover councils hartford councils
somerset and new forest district
councils planning committees
who rejected a similar proposal from
land promoter gladman's over concerns of
local flooding
that their officers had recommended
accepting in the same way tdc
officers are advising tdc planning
committee
constituents have written to all of you
and sent videos evidencing
flooding at shotenden these are your
constituents
and it is their environment that will be
decimated you must
act in the best interests of your
constituents
and reject this prose proposal the 15
affordable offer the objections of local
residents
the four thousand five hundred names on
a petition
the high risk of flooding and
uninsurable
and sellable uninhabitable homes the
strain on local
services the impact on the environment
air quality roads and the multitude of
other valid reasons why this and similar
builds should be rejected
thank you thank you councillor gregory
also speaking as war counsellor council
of parents
[Music]
thank you chair
as fanuc district councillors elected to
represent our valued residents
i strongly urge you to reject this
application
there are so many objections as raised
at the meeting in april
but the paltry rise to 15 of affordable
homes when tdc policy is at least 30
percent
is totally unacceptable as i think most
of you agreed at that meeting in april
we all know sanit is an area of
significant deprivation so the need for
as many affordable homes as possible
must be at the forefront of any planning
application
than it has the second highest child
poverty rates in the south of england
and the highest in kent so it's clear
that 30
affordable housing for any development
in stanley must be the absolute
minimum in addition we actually have
5517
empty homes in phanet what steps have
been taken to bring these into use for
our families in need which would be
preferable to building on our precious
farmland
what about the continuing problem of too
few gps in
thanet in april i stated at the nut that
at the lyme
surgery which serves science to ward
there were approximately five thousand
patients per gp
this has now risen to around 6 000
patients
per gp whereas the national average is
about 2
000 patients per gp this begs the
question what is being done to recruit
more gps to thanit and i've been asking
this question of both kent
and medway clinical commissioning group
and tdc for some time
and i have no satisfactory answer it's
been pointed out that the planning
applications may include the cost of a
new
surgery or an extension but a building
is no use to our residents when there
are no gps to care for them
the application must be refused until
there is a clear plan
from the ccg to recruit more gps to
valid
and what about our treasured and
valuable wildlife there's no mitigation
for loss of farmland birds which
directly contravenes policy sp30
residents know that skylarks nest in
these fields every year and probably for
hundreds of years
this application should be refused until
a complete assessment
of biodiversity on the site has been
completed
including the breeding bird survey which
was promised in 2019
and proper mitigate mitigation measures
have been put in place
finally there is concern that tdc could
be taken to court for rejecting such
applications
but there are many examples as
councillor braidwood has mentioned
councillor gregory has mentioned of
council's councils refusing
planning applications often due to low
levels
of affordable housing in 2018 parkhurst
developers took islington council to the
high court
in a case centered around the viability
assessment
and this was following two lengthy
public inquiries
and this was because it did not meet the
affordable housing
requirement islington council won
and their spokesperson said this
landmark judgment reinforces what
islington and many other councils have
been arguing for years
that affordable housing requirements
cannot be bypassed
by using the dark art of viability
assessments
to ignore planning policy requirements
thank you thank you council parents uh
also speaking under council procedure
20.1
councillor boyd
thank you chair and good evening members
and members of the public
and i don't have too much to say apart
from i just find is desperately
disappointing
that we are going against our own local
plan
and the council is working really really
hard to restore
trust and transparency um amongst the
public and i thought this is
almost a kick in the face to the public
to go against what they voted for
and it's interesting that this report
currently actually states the number of
houses if it were to be 15
is 68. now i've been doing the maths and
even checking it on a calculator even if
it was raised 30
that's 135. so if we look at the figures
if it was accepted 68 just simply isn't
good enough
135 if it was accepted which i hope it
isn't
would be 135 family homes making a
bigger difference
the point i'm making is that if this is
let through on just 15
what happens when the next developer on
an even larger development
goes oh you know what well they got away
with it so i'm just going to go to 15
as well because how little houses is
that going to be is it going to be
another 50
is it going to be another 100 but
actually we need much more than that
and my conservative colleague
councillors pure unfortunately was
going to make it to him it can't be due
to work commitments i will read out his
statements
um he's much more eloquent than me so i
will try and channel his
eloquence here he goes as the committee
will recall i spoke in this application
when it came before the planning
committee
some months ago and raised concerns
about the flood risks of this site and
the surrounding area
along with the insufficient proportion
of affordable housing that was proposed
at the time
unfortunately neither of these concerns
have been addressed in this amended
application
we've seen over the past week the impact
that heavy rainfall hit has on phanet
within shot and dame road turning into a
temporary river and tivoli block
suddenly reappearing above the surface
after the sewage leak
it's clear that southern water cannot
cope with the number of homes in planet
let alone another 450
therefore without any improvements to
the waste treatment plan in this
application it is completely unsuitable
the applicant has now come back with a
revised pros of for affordable housing
and increased from 10 to 15
this is still not policy compliant which
is 30 planet has long waited list long
waiting for affordable homes and many
residents are struggling to get on the
housing ladder
this application does not provide
sufficient affordable housing and the
infrastructure improvements included in
the scheme should not be of a detriment
of providing affordable housing
by accepting a reduction in affordable
housing we are kicking the can further
down the road and i doubt that another
application
will be able to make up the shortfall
and provide more affordable housing than
is policy compliance
we have thousands of homes that have
been granted approval on planet that
haven't yet been built
this is clearly not a demand for another
450 homes but by granting this
application permission it will increase
the risk of
devastating the current devastating the
countryside along shots in the road
therefore i urge the committee to refuse
permission for this scheme
thank you and that's all from both me
and reece
double act councillor boyd
uh thank you for that uh and i will ask
the officer planning officer to outline
the report please
thank you chair
so the application is an outline
application for up to
450 dwellings with open space and
road infrastructure so the site is
outlined
in red it's either side of the shandone
road
this is an aerial view of the site so
you can see
here the two sections of land
the green section to the uh south east
of shandone road and then the section
that's just the north of shondane which
also fronts
hearts down road so the site as
mentioned at the previous committee
uh is allocated in the local plan for up
to 550 homes
under policy sp 21.
so just a recap of the plans for the
development
um the this is
a topographical survey of the site one
of the issues that we talked about last
time was about
the change in topography of the land
from
area a on the um on the of the image
to area b on the image and the change in
land level about 25 meters which
naturally
causes an impact when it comes to
actually developing
the road through area a and area b
this is one of the things that we talked
about at length which is
the surface water flooding on the site
at the moment
which is made up from the model that was
provided by
gladman as part of the application what
it shows
is that there is existing service water
flows on the site
which comes from the south uh southwest
onto the site so this has ended up
dictating the layout of the development
to try and accommodate
and deal with the fact that there is
these existing surface water drainage
flows
which have been formed then the proposed
parameter plans
for the development of the site
so this is the um the proposed
uh sorry parameter plan just showing uh
the developments so
um as mentioned um there is the road
network um
changes that are being proposed so a new
roundabout on shot and dane road
with a new local distributor route to
heartstown road to the north
with then a new route down to a new mini
roundabout on the mansion road
to the south east so that forms part of
the thana inner circuit which is under
policy sp 47. you can see there's open
space
throughout the site the the part to the
the very south
southern corner of the site has a
hatched red line which shows
the archaeological exclusion zone uh
you've then got in the center of the
site around the roundabout you've got an
area of open space there and you can see
the root
of existing surface water drainage flows
that we saw in the previous drawing
running across that northern parcel of
land
and i'll go on and show you the surface
water drainage features that are being
proposed as part of the development
so the darker yellow areas and the
yellow areas
they show different sizes of properties
because it's now that application
we're not looking at the detailed layout
but this is just setting the parameters
for the scheme so the dark yellow areas
which are clustered at the lowest points
of the site
are potentially properties up to three
story
the other areas um are two and a half
story and then the
the sort of much lighter yellow is up to
two-story development
all of those um would be individually
assessed within a reserve matters
application so the further detail would
would be submitted to the council for
consideration
so that just so this is just the images
to confirm that and you can actually see
the
um that there's a bit more of the legend
there about the heights on this site and
again where
that could be in terms of you know the
the where the concentration of the
higher drawings are going to be
um so this is the plan that's been
provided showing
um the green and open space and also the
location of the equipped player is on
the site so you have two
locally equipped play areas that are
proposed on the site
one in the main open space on the
northern section and the other
closer to the mansion road there are
also
local areas of play without equipment
that are also being provided
through the site um there is on the
left-hand side of the image
there is a triangle of blue land which
is safeguarded land
as part of um kent county council's
major road network bid
that land would be uh brought forward as
part of the new road upgrades to
chandaine road so that land is being
safeguarded
and there is a condition which would
propose that
nothing gets built on that with any
reserve matters to ensure that
potentially a link
and realignment of the road can come
forward um the suds feature
um that's being proposed is um is shown
adjacent to the road and see if my mouse
point comes in it does
excellent um which is in this area here
so just off heartstown road
so this is um linked to the surface
water drainage strategy that's been put
in
which has gone through assessment by kcc
as the locally flood authority
um so which would provide acute a basin
with a capacity of 836.
the aim here is to ensure that it
not only reduces the runoff that's
currently in situ
but the principle of the scheme is that
it doesn't increase
any runoff with the development of the
site so the site does not result in
additional runoff
to any of the any of the surrounding
water courses
and that is something that is part of
the planning conditions
and has been signed off by kcc in terms
of
this plan and it's just important to
remind members of
the fact there are um listed buildings
in close proximity
to the site so you have shondane farm um
which is the area that's surrounded by
uh trees which are not
within the site and are proposed to be
all retained
and you then got um to the south east
you've got a number of listed um listed
buildings and structures within the
margate
cemetery and as i mentioned that area of
open space
at the southeast corner is is designed
to ensure that it doesn't actually
there's no development that intrudes on
the archaeology that's been found
through the geophysical surveys that
have been done so that is
to ensure that they are preserved in in
situ
then just to confirm about the proposed
phasing of the development and this is
important in terms of
when the highway infrastructure would be
coming online linked to the scheme
so phase 1a is in green
which will be the first part of the
building that comes forward
the aim here is to ensure that the
infrastructure which provides the link
through
from heartstown road to shotendane road
is in place to ensure that any dwellings
that are occupied off that
arm are served by the links then to
avoid
impact on coffin house corner and
obviously that's one of the main
key issues with this site is to provide
the link through
uh to ensure that um you actually create
a bypass around coffin house corner to
bring
the benefit that comes through the third
transport strategy
um so members considered the application
at the meeting on the 21st of april
and raised various issues
there the application was deferred to
consider alternative provision of
planning obligations with particular
regards to affordable housing
um just to update members since that
last committee meeting we had
12 further objections submitted to us
raising a number of the concerns that
were already put in forward in the
previous committee report but it did
include
further points with regards to the
council's interest in the land
flooding uh the lack of affordable
housing the lack of a detailed breeding
bird
survey and as i mentioned some of the
other issues that are already within the
report when it was reported to you
in april so
following the last meeting that we had
in april the applicant
um responding to some of the points that
were raised and concerns that were
were articulated about the viability
assessment being carried out in june
last year
they looked at the updates for increased
sales values using the nationwide
house price index and then also looked
at the
rix building cost information service
for uh to understand what the changes
have been in terms of build costs in
that time
it showed a six percent increase in
sales values in the out of south
east and three percent
uh build cost increase so those um
increases were fed into the viability
assessment that has already been
independently assessed by the council's
appointed viability consultants who also
did the full plan viability as well
um and that has resulted in an increased
amount of affordable housing
that the applicant is putting forward um
that could be provided
and that is on the basis of 80
of those properties being affordable
rent and 20
of them being shared ownership and as
already mentioned
um if um the development was built out
providing the 450 homes
that this development could bring as an
up to that equates to
about 23 more dwellings above the
previous 10
to give a total of 68 of which 53 are
affordable rent
now the report that you've got in front
of you
outlines uh the wording of um
the affordable housing policy that's
already been mentioned sp
23 at 3.1
and it's it's just important that the
end of that policy
is also understood by members that it's
that the requirements of the 30 target
will only be reduced if meeting them
would demonstrably make the proposed
development unviable
as outlined in the previous committee
report and in this report
this assessment the viability assessment
has been reviewed by
um dixon cell who did the council's full
viability
and that confirms that it is the case
that if more affordable housing was
provided at the same
split that it would make the development
unviable now that is on the basis of the
planning obligations
that are outlined in the heads of terms
at
annex six so that includes 4.9 million
of contributions which is split out to
various
um various different elements of kcc um
the contribution towards the ccg
as well as the contribution towards the
strategic access management and
monitoring plan
um therefore it is recommended by
officers that the heads of terms with 15
affordable housing are accepted by
members because it complies with policy
sp 23 but only
with the review mechanisms that are
outlined in that heads of those heads of
terms
which would reassess viability before
the occupation of the 200th dwelling on
site and before the occupation of the
400th dwelling on site
because as shown just by the last year
the increase in values
can have a big impact on viability so to
put these review provisions in
will allow that to be captured with a
contribution
coming to the council um there is um one
other review mechanism that's being
proposed and i did talk about this last
time indeed
james rate when he was here well not
here in the virtual meeting
in april talks about this which is about
the major road network funding stream
that's available
and that could mean that the road
network
that you can see in front of you part of
those development costs
could be taken up by the department of
transport if the bid is successful
for many road developments and
improvements are across
thanet what this review mechanism that
would be in the heads of terms
would then require is that the money
that would have been spent on roads
comes back to the council and gets spent
on planning obligations including
affordable housing
um now the report picks up some of the
other matters that were raised at the
meeting
last time at 5.1 5.2 and 5.3
on the the principal issues of
developing the site um as i've
mentioned at the last committee um the
site is an allocated housing site
um it's the question for members is
about how it gets developed not about
whether or not it gets developed because
it's it is allocated
um the response specifically um
to the the points that have been raised
about um
lack of a lack of gps and attraction to
gps is dealt with in the report 5.2
and also um drainage specifically with
regards to
uh 5.3 which i've already covered when
when talking through
the application and i'm happy to answer
any questions
specifically about those issues or
indeed any other issues that members
members
want some some clarification on um so
the application is recommended by
officers
to defer for approval subject to
securing a legal movement for the
provision of 50 affordable housing
and contributions and subject to the
safeguarding conditions that are
outlined in
annex six thank you chair
uh thank you ian um i moved as the
officer's recommendation
is adopted could the vice chair please
second
i'll second that yeah thank you
councillor coleman cook
members uh open this to yourselves
counselor joel bayford thank you chair
um first of all i'd like to say that i
have found the level
and tone of lobbying on this application
intimidating
we are asked as members of the planning
committee to come to meetings
with with no predetermination and i fail
to see how this kind of lobbying helps
i think we should be allowed to make our
own decisions based on what we see in
here
tonight i've listened carefully to what
our speakers and officers have said
i think that this site has a lot in
favor
um as mr livingston pointed out we are
we should be looking at
how the site is developed not whether it
should be developed however
i would like to hear what other speakers
have to say before i make my decision
thank you uh thanks counselor bayford
i'm looking for hands council fellows
thank you chairman uh mr chairman i'm
troubled by this application as
many others as we heard tonight so i'd
like to share my thoughts
uh planet officers will tell us that we
as councillors voted for the local plan
and the allocated
plots of lands in it i must add that i
didn't do that
but we also voted for all the policies
within the local plan
and one of the fundamental policies is
the minimum of 30 affordable homes
here we are being asked to agree to half
of that which is just not acceptable
i appreciate the viability issues for
the applicant if they can't make it
viable
following our policies then they should
pass it to a developer who can or if
it's unviable
then so be it but the affordable homes
target is not just the only issue here
with this development the local plan is
not just about building as many homes as
possible
it's about future aspirations for our
residents and building sustainable
communities
plonking 450 homes in a field with what
could be around 1500 people is certainly
not sustainable
there's a gp shortage in that and that's
at crisis point
the residents of this development as
we've heard already will be at the in
the catchment area
already at bursting point we can also
see four or five hundred children on
this development
has anybody checked if there are
sufficient school places i'm presuming
not
and please don't even get me started on
dental services invented
personally i'd like to see a moratorium
on all decisions all these massive
developments coming down the track
including this one
until ccgs can guarantee healthcare for
all our residents
and for all the newcomers that will
occupy these houses
and guarantees from kcc that there will
be school places within walking distance
i appreciate there are penalties if this
is refused this evening and later
granted on appeal
but this should not be a reason for
accepting this application and committee
members should not be fearful
we also listened to the kcc
representative at the previous uh
meeting stating that this development is
necessary
so as to fund the last link of the
planned relief bypass ring road
these are roads that kcc should be
funding themselves and should have been
built years ago
but now we want to burden our area with
houses built on grade one agricultural
land so we can get a few roundabouts and
votes
uh i thought i can't support this
application this evening thank you mr
chairman
uh thank you council fellows uh mr
levinson wishes just to come back
thank you i just wanted to come back on
the point with regards to school places
it is
it's covered in the committee report um
that
kcc obviously provide us um
a consulting response specifically
looking at the requirement for new
school places as part of any housing
development over 10 houses
so that is covered as one of the
contributions that would come forward as
part of the development which is
obviously the way that increases in in
schools
are are funded um i just wanted to again
reiterate
the point that i raised earlier about
the site in itself
is is allocating the local plan so in
terms of um
the the principle of developing this
site
um i i cannot see that there is a cogent
reason for refusal for members on the
principal
issue of developing the site because it
is an adopted site in the local plan
thank you chair
uh thank you in cancer
thank you chair um we all know about
this
um and we're going to have more of these
so i mean it it this is not
just a one-off decision this this will
impact upon other decisions we make in
the council regarding
um local plans and adopted land and
where pic house is going to be built
i do have issues um a couple of them
are the flood issues i mean i've seen
shot and down road absolutely flooded i
can't see
how building another 1500 houses on
um an air that regularly floods is going
to
be of benefit um southern water
as we all know had a sewage break that
has affected the whole community
as well as um further flung people want
to come on holiday etcetera
if they can't cope with the number of
houses now how they're going to cope
with another 1500 here or wherever
they're going to be built and my third
one is
realistically we did agree
as a council and as um
a group within the whole authentic that
we would have 30
affordable housing that has to be
achieved we had one came in the other
week
where lng said we can do this if they
can do it then i'm sure other companies
can do it they just don't
want to do it and i think that just
needs to be addressed and i think we
need to make sure that we stand firm on
the 30
whether that means that this company
cannot make it viable doesn't mean to
say another company cannot
and i think that has to be born in mind
i'm not against and i'm not trying to go
against local plan you know we need to
build houses i understand that
but i do think we need to build it in a
way that is going to help everybody in
the community
not just the people who can afford to
buy a house thank you chair
uh thank you council heart um i will
hand back to uh
mr lewis i just think it's just
important in terms of
differences with other sites obviously
what we talked about in the last meeting
in april is specifically with regards to
this site
and the challenge for this site in terms
of viability which predominantly comes
from
the infrastructure requirements of
having roads that are built to both
local distributed standard but also
two roundabouts being built uh on a land
which
has a level change of over 25 meters
which has an engineering costs and these
are some of the detailed costs that we
looked at in a qs survey
again separately independently looked at
to ensure those costs were sound
within the viability assessment in terms
of the example of the
westwood lodge site and providing 30
on on that uh there is no infrastructure
requirements on that site at all for 150
because of where it's located and i've
seen a different value area
um for where it is so it's just
important that those distinctions are
made
when when coming to this decision thank
you sir
uh thank you in case
thank you chair our local plan says 30
affordable housing because that's what
we need and in particular we need family
homes
of the last or first proposal uh the
affordable housing was
allocated mainly as flats and i don't
see anywhere on the second proposal that
it actually states
what um the mix of housing would be but
it's family homes that we need
the reduction obviously half from 135 to
68
is significant i understand the
viability issues
but the fact is for all our big
developments it is bound to create a
road infrastructure
cost and therefore we are always going
to come up against this problem of
viability
um in a previous um
proposal not for this site for a
different site
we agreed a reduced rate of
affordable housing and we were told very
clearly at the time that that would not
set a precedent
but it seems to me every large
development that comes before us
does reduce the amount of affordable
housing and i find that unacceptable
thank you cancer
i nearly called you council again ian
please
just on the mix of housings the mix of
housing isn't
fixed within the outline application in
terms of the affordable housing as part
of a proportion
of um of that mix
the adopted mix that they've taken the
viability assessment
is the mix that's in the local plan in
terms of the amount of flats so they've
mimicked exactly the market housing
as if it was the affordable housing so
in terms of a higher proportion of flats
that is simply
that way it's not the case when it comes
to actually looking at again the market
housing in comparison to the affordable
housing so it's the same mix
uh thank you ian um just a point of
information for me before i come back to
members and i have got some names down
it was noted after we discussed this
application
um the last time around that myself as
chair
i won't use the exact wording which
appeared on social media
but basically said a few things that i
turned to
the planning officer on numerous
occasions and i wonder why that is
the reason i turn to the planning
offices
as as we have legal here tonight
is to make sure that things are said
correctly
and right they have everything at their
fingertips
us as members we have reports
i just wanted to get that over that i'm
not in
mr livingston's back pocket um
and i think everybody knows what i'm
talking about there
and i've just taken advice whether i'm
allowed to say that which
i am so that's why
i turn to the officers for their advice
and i think members know that but there
are
members of the public here and i want
them to know that as well
thank you councillor hopkinson
thank you chair um i just want to
firstly say um
thanks to all the members of the public
that have submitted uh comments on this
including
members of the public in the gallery uh
at the moment and also i just wanted in
particular to mention the
save our fields uh film which we were
all sent
um i hope i know by contrast that
glyphons have not
sent a representative tonight to um to
speak for their proposal um
i just wanted to pick out the one
particular issue which has been spoken
about a lot which is the failure to meet
the 30
provision of affordable housing which i
agree with a lot of people a lot of
views of express night is so important
that we are doing everything we can to
to meet to meet that figure and that
developers are
aware that we're a council that wants
that figure to be met
um and on that point i mean so we're
advised that
that figure isn't isn't viable with with
this proposal
the report says that sir gradman's
gradman's estimate their own
projection is they'll make um 19.8
million pounds profit
from the proposal as they as they see it
unless i'm misunderstanding
the figures so if that's the case i do
struggle to see uh you know the issue of
viability there i mean
perhaps it's to do with percentages of
margins etc but close to 20 million
pounds profit seems to be
a comfortable margin so i do struggle to
understand why we should accept
a um proposal that doesn't meet what we
as a council i think consider to be a
very very important
figure for the residents of thalet in
terms of affordable housing
i think i wasn't present at the the
previous
planning meeting um where this proposed
the initial version of this proposal was
was uh discussed but i understand that
that
you know at that point the the um offer
was for 10 percent affordable housing
and i believe we were advised that the
committee was advised at the time
that you know that that on the grounds
of
it not being viable to go above that
that it should be accepted
so i just it makes me feel uh
you know i'm wondering how can we get to
being confident that this 15
actually now really is a figure that
actually uh can't be extended if that
was
if we were advised that the 10 figure
was previously something that couldn't
be uh
couldn't be reached the points were made
about you know
we in principle in the local plan have
allocated this land
for development sorry accept our points
um but there is you know as we keep
mentioning this there then that is
another principle in the local plan so
it doesn't seem to me to be you know
necessary that we have to contradict one
aspect of the local plan for the other
one
so i i have these serious concerns about
the 30
allocation the failure to meet it
uh thank you councillor hawkins and uh
mr laurenson coming back
um you're correct council considers it's
about margins
um so the the total amount is based on a
percentage of
gross development value uh full
developer profit
which is the government set out in the
national planning practice guidance the
full viability assessments um that you
can look at a range of
15 to 20 gross development value
um in this instance um the the the
appraisal takes
17.5 so it goes down the middle
and that was the approach that's been
taken on a number of other
viability assessments that the council
looks at
um just to come back on um the point
with regards to
um i think you mentioned our
representation um
obviously there's no public speaking at
the meeting because there's an agenda
item so that's that's
the the point with regards to uh with
regards to that
uh thank you chad uh thank
you and council ghana
thank you chair um yeah
council orchestra yeah i was like a
number of us
at the meeting when we discussed these
two committees
um i know seven of us um voted to reject
the application of that
i've i raise along with others a number
of issues
um around one around biodiversity or the
lack of
some of the biodiversity service surveys
one's been mentioned the breeding bird
survey
which um we've we found was missing
um i haven't been um
satisfied that the as we've seen last
week
that this land is suitable in terms of
flooding
um flooding we've seen
the floods up that road just the last
week and i don't
see how this this land can be suitable
based on that
um the ccg contribution okay i
understand that might have been accepted
but various people have made the point
this evening that um
but it's not just bricks and mortar that
we need and we really need to find a
solution to be able to attract
the medical professionals to the area
who are going to actually
um staff those bricks and mortar
buildings that would get built
maybe as a result of this application
and council hopkinson mate makes an
excellent point
about the um cost versus profit
as that's highlighted in annex seven the
the appraisal summary i mean it does
see but i make it i find it difficult to
accept
that uh the 20 million profit
off of this proposal isn't enough
um to provide thirty percent housing i
mean i can accept
i assume that the four point nine
million contributions
for section 106 uh and others come from
that profit
but even so i can't i find it very
difficult to accept
that there's still a cut by half in the
amount of
affordable housing that should be
allocated here
um i remember um councillor keane
mentioned a previous application
that came before us where we got an
appraisal summary
and after much um discussion
much i'd say even heartache among some
of us
we were persuaded to accept a cut i
think it was to 18
um most of us with a heavy heart and i
believe we saw well i certainly
um felt that that was the one time that
i could do that and
i find it very very very difficult
to accept any proposal now any
application
that offers anything less than 30
affordable housing
when it's something that is desperately
needed in the district
so thank you thank you council ghana um
bring back mister
um apologies mums i haven't covered the
breeding birds issue and that is
something that
i think is important to cover so um the
the application was accompanied by an
environmental
statement under the eia regs which
included a phase one habitat survey that
was carried out
um this was looked at by um kcc
biodiversity offices
um and natural england as part of the
statutory consultation
that we we carry out um a specific
breeding bird survey wasn't asked for by
kcc um biodiversity
following their assessment of the
information that was submitted
but obviously was looked at in the round
by natural england when considering the
council's habitat regulations assessment
which is
one of the annexes in your report
and what that outlines and is outlined
within the environmental statement
is sufficient mitigation to ensure that
there will not be
a significantly adverse impact on
breeding birds on the site and that's
enshrined in two particular planning
conditions condition
31 and condition 41. 31
is an ecological design strategy which
will actually
ensure that there is sufficient
mitigation for the protected species
that are identified
within the environmental statement and
number 41 is further mitigation which
is actually in the form of a homeowner
pack which will have to come forward
with any new dwelling that's constructed
which is basically outlining how what
residents can do to
avoid impacting on any species that are
being accommodated on the
site which is um which is a a scheme
that's been
obviously provided for in this instance
natural england have agreed the habitat
regulations assessment and have
confirmed therefore that
um on that side of things that they
don't consider there is
that the impact is not mitigated
sufficiently
and therefore we do think that that
issue has been sufficiently dealt with
through both the conditions
um and in consultation with natural
england and
kcc biodiversity um
thank you thank you ian
do i see any other members cancel my
head
thank you chair i'm afraid brevity isn't
my strongest point
but i promise i do try my best and so
for brevity i'll speak only on the issue
that's particularly close to my heart
namely affordable housing and sp23
affordable housing is the cornerstone of
progress the planet
we are in desperate need of affordable
housing and it isn't just our area
that's struggling
there are many areas that currently
struggle with what is considered to be
low land value and thanos is one of them
what we see as a result of this is a
continuing struggle to provide
affordable housing
as we're not funded in that sense by
central government to do so at the level
required
and have to rely on private development
to deliver levels anywhere near our
actual need
we are in effect forced by central
government and central legislation to
rely on private development to help
deliver essential infrastructure and
services
and sufficient affordable housing the
problem being that private developers
are not required to consider
residents needs and council's needs
above the overall picture in terms of
financial viability
i've been in several planning meetings
now where the issue of proportion
in terms of affordable housing has
arisen
each time i become more and more
frustrated and more and more angry at
the strictures of central legislation
and systems that insist that councils
have control
was knowing full well that ultimate
control in terms of funding
reliance on private development and the
ability of councils to provide
infrastructure
nice centrally in the current system
where we are not given sufficient
central funding to build social and
affordable housing sufficient for our
need
and are therefore required to rely on
private development to deliver it
the 30 delivery of affordable housing
under sb
23 is vitally important
just as important is the type of housing
delivered
than it desperately needs affordable
rent but currently financial viability
determines even the delivery of that
as of the types of affordable housing
affordable rent is the least profitable
i have a fundamental issue with this and
it's why i struggle with any system that
combines profit with care or essential
service
because when situations like this arise
the two are incompatible
right now we are effectively held over a
barrel
those of us who have worked with housing
know just how difficult the situation is
we have to provide affordable housing we
are not given sufficient central funding
to do so on our own
and so time and time again we are faced
with the dilemma of financial viability
issues
told that we need to accept 10 or 15
rather than the required 30
or residents will go without and we are
left with that choice
to provide for some even though it's
nowhere near the amount sufficient to
deal with our need
or to reject and accept that those
families will remain in need for the
immediate future
and hope that either the development
changes or that another comes in this
place that fulfills our needs as an area
i wrote to robert genwick mp last month
to add my voice to the numbers of
councils expressing just this problem
as i have not had a reply as yet my
concerns still stand
central legislation requires us to have
a local plan
it requires us to adhere to planning
algorithms
it requires us to rely on private
development to deliver essential housing
and services
because in spite of our knowledge of our
area and our needs as a council
we are not given the direct funding to
build ourselves
and when we are faced yet again with
those circumstances forcing us to accept
or reject a drop in our essential
affordable housing requirement
we are forced to choose between
providing for some or providing for none
when we should be able to provide for
all
if affordable housing is an afterthought
and unaffordable
then central government needs to step up
and address those funding gaps
if councils cannot afford essential
infrastructure and services
even after relying on private
development then central government
needs to address that
we are here to decide on individual
planning cases
but it is impossible to do so
effectively without considering the
larger picture when issues like this
continually come to the surface
and we are doing the system as a whole
disservice when we do not speak on these
issues
and we do our community a disservice in
not explaining the complexities and
difficulties of these systems
planning does not exist in isolation it
exists as a function of central
government
delegated to local councils who then
struggle to explain just how thoroughly
their hands are tied even within that
delegated authority
we are here as a council to provide we
should be able to do that ourselves
as we have the local knowledge and
understanding to build well and
sympathetically
but if we cannot and we have to rely on
private development to deliver what is
needed
then what is needed has to be the main
priority and central government has to
support us
in the delivery of essential services to
our communities
and if recognition of that has to begin
in council chambers across the country
then that is what will happen in sanet
we face some of the most difficult
social and financial challenges in the
uk
every single day we have done for all of
my lifetime
but we do so because as an area we
accept that our lives are intrinsically
linked with those of others
regardless of how difficult it is we do
not step away and we serve our community
as a community we do not accept that we
can provide for no one
we do not accept that we can only
provide for some
we provide for all and although i
acknowledge the review measures and the
efforts of planning
to my mind if sp 23 is to function for
this area
it has to function to its capacity and
that requires all levels of government
including this committee looking at how
planning functions for all of us
thank you thank you councillor whitehead
counselor more pet more
thank you chem we've talked
a lot about houses which we do
desperately need
we also need food to sell
land to build houses on is is a bit of a
funny thing when we're going to lose
land that feeds us
they're actually growing food on it
they're going to feed us so what will we
do when it's gone
we've we've come out of europe so we're
having to find new trade agreements
it's not going to be cheaper than it was
before so food
is going to be more expensive and i
think
there are a lot of hungry people going
to be knocking about
i think we could build houses somewhere
else
but i thought we'd stop building on
green land
obviously not so we need houses
but we need food thank you chairman
uh thank you councilmoor
do you wish to no fine uh councillor
joe bayford thank you chair
whatever members may feel this site has
been allocated for housing and for that
reason
i am very concerned that if this
application is lost or
lost it will be overturned on appeal and
i
think that this is this is a cost that
this council cannot afford
for that reason i wonder
mr slimston do you feel there is any way
that the amount of
affordable housing may be increased
it's the one issue that i personally am
still concerned about
yes
sorry uh thank you chair
um the the debate is very similar to
the discussions that we've had before
members about samson grange which was
the site that's been referenced
um in terms of the evidence that's been
presented by the applicant which has
then been as i say assessed
and looked into um obviously what that
is based on
is 80 of those affordable units being
affordable rent
20 of them being shared ownership one of
the things that we also
looked at was to see whether or not the
increase of
uh you know there could be an increased
proportion of affordable housing
from looking at the the government's
recently announced first homes
which is something that some of you will
be aware of and will perform past
separate separate training
um and but it wouldn't it wouldn't do
that
the way that you would increase the
proportion of affordable housing on the
basis of the evidence that's been
presented
um is is twofold one is
you reduce the amount of affordable rent
which is obviously not something that
the council
as officers would support because it
goes against our housing strategy
uh that could potentially increase
obviously the value of the affordable
housing
to then increase the overall proportion
of affordable housing
the other scenario is the one that's
presented
in the report to members which is that
effectively councillors could decide
that they would minimize the
contributions that would go to
kcc and the nhs and uh the
not uh you know to reduce that uh
the the overall amount um that you know
that would then
potentially increase it but the scenario
that's been put forward which we've
we've checked would basically be if you
reduce that amount of contributions by
75 percent
um you only increase the amount of
affordable housing up to 19
so you don't um you don't necessarily
get a lot of benefit
on the financial side of things um
in terms of members concerns about the
issues of affordable housing
um it is it is obviously the case that
everyone is absolutely correct the
target is 30 that is
what we want to achieve um the the
policy
has the very specific line at the end
because and the reason why that lines in
there
is because that is what the government
states
should be the the case that we should
look at when sites are not viable
because of particular reasons
um and development still should be
provided for other reasons
um that we should look at which
requirements
are needed and if the development will
be unviable because of it
but it also provides other benefits then
um playing inspectors
and you know it's shown in appeals will
will drop down and agree less affordable
housing or less contributions
because they would consider the benefits
our way
um and i appreciate that therefore it's
a very difficult decision
for members to agree a reduction to 15
um but fundamentally the the site
has quite tangible clear benefits
um that will be weighed quite heavily in
support
um obviously the council at the moment
cannot count
meet the housing delivery test um which
means that we are in a presumption state
which can
result in applications coming in outside
of our urban confines
and great weight is given or stated by
the government to be given to the
provision of housing
in those sites so for an allocated site
to come forward
is something that we obviously look to
support in this instance obviously it's
bringing forward key infrastructure
and it is also making a provision of
affordable housing
but that is not to the target but they
have demonstrated
and obviously the information has been
provided to members about this
that viability information is there uh
in the in the pack
um that shows that they have
demonstrated it would be unviable
uh if you increase the amount um to one
of the points that's been mentioned
um which is effectively how can you
trust officers if we've said 10
is okay and now suddenly 15 i do think
it's important
to touch on this values will change over
time
that is inevitable in a in a market that
is exactly why we have proposed the
review mechanisms
so that if we if members had accepted
the 10
and then when they build out the scheme
and they get to the 200th dwelling
we rerun all the viability using the
same inputs as we do
but with actual costs and actual sales
values
we would get a proportion of that
surplus
to go back into affordable housing
that's the point of the legal agreement
that's the point of why we need that
sort of obligation so
it is captured either way um
in terms of the value in the uplift of
the site thank you chair
uh thank you ian um thank you for that
councillor wayford uh
councillor hall thank you chair
um i understand
most of what's going on on this planning
issue um i'm just a bit concerned
or confused still with regards to
what ian said about if the road is then
funded by kent um that we get a wedge of
money
um can that ma will that money be spent
on affordable housing on that
site is question one and question
two i might have missed it in in the
report sorry
um question two is if
that wedge of money comes to us i don't
know how much it is i've got no idea how
much a road cost to build
um would that not be better that the
builder
puts that into affordable housing so we
actually achieve the 30 percent
thank you uh thank you hartman
um so the mechanism is that yeah if
if kcc's bid is successful with the
department of transport
the the money that would have been spent
on particular roads within this
development which formed part of that
bid
would basically be funded with some
match funding by the developer
so it's not entirely all of the costs of
the road
that would be provided by the dft there
has to be some funding from a developer
to match fund to it to an extent of a
percentage
um this is it is in the report
um the annex six report um the total
savings
could total 3.6 million
minus the match funding which the match
funding amount hasn't been fixed yet by
kcc
um but the proportion of that would be
around that sort of total that
is specifically being earmarked for
for three things affordable housing um
and the contributions
towards the kcc contributions which
from the report you'll see uh there is
currently a um
sort of tariff-capped amount of kcc
contributions so it could increase that
up to the request that's been made
so it's those two things that it would
come to um in terms of your point about
whether or not it could be on-site
it's proposed because of when the
funding would actually come forward
it's likely to come forward later on
because of the way that the funding
works that
it's not expected for a decision until
uh potentially it might be 2023
and obviously depending on how the
development goes on it would be a
contribution
which would then be fixed for affordable
housing projects in
potentially margate or depending on you
know on the area
that that would actually be able to be
the money would be used for by our
housing team
so it would be off it would be an
off-site contribution
thank you thank you and um
okay i don't see any other speakers
so members i think a very good debate
once again
uh and it's over to you if i may here so
i will now put the motion of the
officer's recommendation which is to
defer
for approval to yourselves
those in favor
those against
those abstaining i'm going to abstain
so that motion has been lost
so if you can bear with me a few moments
members and
uh members of the public i'll just come
to
mr livingston yes yes
and some members um obviously i
mentioned a number of points
um obviously the issues that are raised
in the report clearly identify um about
needing to have codes and reasons for
refusal for an application and obviously
the main issue that has obviously come
back
is that this hasn't met the 30
target with regards to affordable
housing that's the obviously the main
sort of dominating issue
that's been raised obviously at the
moment
we have no evidence to um to say
that the evidence that's been produced
by the applicant
and also been independently checked by
our consultants
is incorrect so it does leave us in a
position
where a refusal on that ground on its
own
um would need to be justified against
the evidence some extent that we've
obviously been provided now i obviously
mentioned
with regards to issues certain issues
such as profit levels
for example where the input there is a
range of inputs that
that could be put forward um obviously
my recommendation
would always be to ensure that the
council has a robust reason for refusal
um and obviously in this instance um i
don't
i don't believe members are saying they
don't agree with dicks and cells work
that they've done on both this sort of
full plan viability
but it's it's that effectively you would
but i mean
what i would suggest in this instance is
actually getting a second opinion
if you wanted but it is entirely up to
you if if members consider that they
would want to refuse the applications
being contradicted 23
then a member could move that motion
it does not give officers much ground
though
to argue that appeal because we have no
evidence to suggest
that what's been confirmed by our
viability consultants is incorrect
so i i opened up for discussion
thank you
thank you um yeah what about i mean you
said you based it on 17.5
percent so what about if that was
reduced to 15
which is the lower limit of accepted
viability does that
make enough difference
um i i don't know what that does
to the scenario in terms of if you fed
that into
an appraisal done by a an appointed
consultant
i don't know what that would do in terms
of improvements to viability
so that's one obviously that's one
factor um
it may be that it doesn't increase it to
the
30 and all the other inputs which
obviously have already been
independently checked
would still then stay the same um
i think the the the normal procedure
potentially would be and this is
enshrined in the in the protocol
um is that if obviously members want to
refuse the application on this basis
um that there is a lack of affordable
housing um
that effectively um we outline in a
report to you what that reason for
refusal looks like
and we would try and put together a case
um to see if it would would hold and
stand together
obviously we have looked at this issue
already you know that is what obviously
the report is before you tonight looks
at um
but if members wish to refuse it on the
basis of the evidence that they have
before them they can do that but the
report obviously does make it clear
about the risk that that does pose
so uh thank you and um
thank you for that council clean uh
members
council heart thank you chair um
i mean there was a couple of points not
it's not only affordable housing which
seems to be the main
um bug bearer of all of us councillors
that
are here tonight and i think that's a
fair and justified
reason for refusal but also there's the
the issue we have with flooding there's
the issues we have
with um as other councils
said you know there's there's no dental
practices there's no
i i i know ian that you you you pick on
that but that
it's the overall scope that this is
involving
it's not just the fact that it's not
affordable housing it's the fact that
whether this is right for this area
because
that road flooded all the time and and i
think that this is all part and parcel
of that same thing
and maybe i'm wrong maybe you can you
can put me in the right direction but if
if this goes to appeal
the worst thing that can happen surely
is that
it gets agreed by the appeal body
and it sits as it is now um so
it's it's a no lose situation for the
council effectively it can't get any
worse than it is now or am i wrong and
if so
please put me right because you know if
it means that if it goes to appeal
and we only get 10 affordable housing
that becomes an issue
for us as members to to consider but if
it
goes to a pill and they lose then it's a
win situation but if it comes back as
exactly the same we've lost nothing by
going to appeal
um just to pick up one point about
flooding
um obviously we are guided by
the expert advice we get from kcc as the
local lead flood authority
um there they have agreed the strategy
for
surface water drainage on this site the
provisions that have been put forward to
reduce the rate of flows as a result of
housing development
have been considered acceptable the
condition that would mitigate this
is the way you deal with flooding
in planning effectively if you agree the
strategy then you get the detailed
scheme in when the layout is fixed you
ensure that you've got
all of the various mitigation measures
in place so
from the officer perspective i don't
consider there to be a cogent reason for
refusal on
flooding because it's it would be on the
basis i appreciate
the site floods i you know because we've
seen it with the surface water drainage
flows
but it's an anecdotal suggestion that
actually isn't backed up by evidence
that this development would result in
flooding we don't have any evidence of
that
that's that's the the one one of the key
issues
um in terms of going to appeal
um the the point of
the the the role of of of planning
committees obviously to make
the planning decisions on matters such
as this but we must
um you know can only advise you about
how to make the cogent decisions based
on
on planning considerations if
if an application goes to appeal and is
overturned obviously yes that would
grant consent for what has been refused
what that would obviously result in is
cost to the council
from dealing with that appeal from
administration costs to
costs um again if it goes to a hearing
or public inquiry
that's a cost of a barrister etc all of
those elements come into play
but fundamentally the costs regime is
the issue
if the council refuses an application on
unreasonable grounds
without any evidence that's a cost award
where we pay for the other side's cost
as well now i accept the fact that
in terms of the planning judgment that
doesn't come into play it's not about
avoiding costs in terms of the judgment
we make it's actually about the
the the actual judgment the decision
needs to be based on planning reasons
and that's why i will always suggest
that if members want
to refuse something there's got to be
some evidence behind it there's got to
be something to back up
that claim now in this instance
affordable housing being the issue
that's come up
particularly we have obviously looked at
the viability assessment and have agreed
that
but if members do think that they
consider that more affordable housing
should or could be provided
on the basis that you've read the
information that's been provided
then that is a case that we can look
into
and and try and support appeal as as
best as we can
but fundamentally is a decision for
members to make on the basis of the
information that we've we've presented
to you
thank you
um that don't sorry if i can come back
on that chair so that doesn't really
answer the question in
uh what i asked you was that
as an officer as the planning officer if
we go we we stick with our decision as
it is now
okay and it goes to a pill
will that put us in a worse situation
ignore the finances i'm talking whether
the decision
would be would he put in an appeal for
15
or would he get 5 or what will the
decision
i'm not saying you can prejudge the
decision but you know what i mean
we can't be in a worse position or we
could be
sorry just because i slipped into my
longer point i'm so apologies um
the applicant has submitted it on the
basis of 15 and on the basis of the
heads of terms they're there so that is
what members are considering that is the
planning application that we're
considering and that would be what's
then
if your members decide to refuse the
application that is then what is
appealed
um that i you know i i
we would be working on the basis that
that is what the applicant is proposing
and that is then what's proposed to the
inspector
and the inspector would then determine
it on the basis of that provision
an inspector wouldn't wouldn't
arbitrarily reduce that
in making their decision because that
would be the applicant's submission to
them
so that would be what they would be
considering
thank you council karma thank you yeah
this this um this application has been
before us
twice we've had um reports
so a lot the same reports but we've had
copious reports
on this with a lot of evidence that
we've listened to we've read the reports
we've listened to the officers
statements on this and we've had our
concerns
and we've rejected what what has been
proposed
as a committee and so i think
i would propose that we we don't keep
going backwards and forwards
looking for new different ways of
solutions we've quite categorically
rejected this proposal um on
the grounds of
affordable housing one of them but also
we have rejected this
on we've rejected the evidence around
the liability to flood in
and we've rejected the evidence that
we've got
around adequate health cover the ccg
contribution
we've as a as a committee have said that
it's inadequate
so i think we've spoken quite clearly
that we don't
accept this application and i propose
that we should
reject it along those grounds
uh thank you council
i'm going to go to uh mr livingston just
to
finalize i do understand myself where
you're coming from here but
with the flooding as it's been mentioned
and this is
me you know i'm looking at the whole
thing again um
i understand what you're getting at but
with the flooding side until
it there's nothing there at the moment
to say that's going to have a
you know adverse effect if i make sense
um because we don't know we don't know
oh sorry that's right thanks um
just on the ccg point i appreciate i
appreciate the perspective that
obviously this is a concern
that's come up the ccg have requested
a contribution i understand there is
concern about the lack of
um of of gps in the area
the report we've put forward makes it
very clear that that is not as a direct
result of this development
again it's it would in
in our view and that is that's all i can
can provide to members
it would be unreasonable to refuse on
those grounds there's no policy to hinge
that
on and fundamentally the decision has to
be based on
the development plan policies um yes
thank you chair
uh thank you ian um council keen
just to come back uh to ian's point
um does it not state in the local plan
something about making sure that the
health needs of the community are met
um it does and that's why we asked the
ccg for their view
and they've agreed the mitigation that's
been
requested so again there's no there's no
reason that
you're right
council right mr chairman i'm i'm sorry
to go back
on to the issue about the um 30
um this is not the first application
that we've had
where we i feel that we're being held
held to ransom
over over the affordable housing is
there any way mr livingstone
that we can make it clear to any
developer that's going to come into the
area
30 is the requirement in planet and
that's what
it is not negotiable thank you
the local plan policy sp 23 specifically
cites that if it's if if it will be
unviable that's the only reason why we
reduce the 30 percent so it's it states
that in the policy that's been it's the
adopted policy
so that that makes it clear again linked
to government guidance on this exact
point that we must consider at the
viability case
that's put forward um i think just as a
as another point if you know the the
reason for refusal
for members on this on affordable
housing would
is is very is straightforward in its
wording
which is that the development would fail
to provide 30 affordable housing
as on on the site contrary to sp23 um
but you know again that
that reason would would be um
you know would have to effectively
bypass the evidence
in front of you and that is you know
that's that's the office of view but
it's it's for members to decide
members um i did say earlier on we have
our chief
um this is with us tonight estelle
um uh we'd like to say just a few words
and
clarify a few things thank you thanks
very much chair yeah i mean
the point has been very well made by ian
but you do have to be
very careful to think about this
evidence base
because the point on affordability and
we absolutely understand the concerns
is that the applicants has put forward
their
expert report on viability but we have
got an expert
independent assessment of that viability
so that
is our evidence so what ian is saying um
is that you know in order to negate that
evidence
we have to go we have to go somewhere
else so
it's not enough simply to say well we
don't we don't accept the evidence on
viability
we as a council have already got an
independent assessment that the
viability assessment is correct
and that's the difficulty so um
just to just to reiterate that points
uh thank you so council keen
thank you so i mean going back then do
we need to
to put forward that we think a lower
percentage
profit would you know should be employed
in this thing because what we need
is affordable housing for the area so
doing the 15 figure rather than the 17.5
the issue is um that that the
the reduction of the profit amount
wouldn't necessarily
equate to achieving 30 because of the
issues on this site particularly with
regards to the abnormal costs
of road infrastructure and topography um
in terms of a refusal on the grounds of
being conjured sp
23 then indeed that sort of issue
would be part of the council's case to
say well we think that that should be
reduced
on that basis um but
the the issue is um is whether or not
again we would look to try and
potentially come back to you with a case
which looks at that
and looks at any other issues that we
can find that we can argue
to put it to members or alternatively we
would look to try and put that forward
um after the event but the problem is
that's not what members are
that's not actually what members are
considering now you're considering the
evidence before you
and that makes it clear that the the
evidence that we've got
he's effectively agreeing with the
applicant's evidence
so if members and uh
public wouldn't mind obviously come back
well so we don't totally understand and
i do as well
as chair what is being said here tonight
and
it's got to be done i think you'll know
it's got to be done correctly
um thanks just in terms of um the
conversation just had um
as as alluded to earlier the
recommendation for officers
would be effectively to uh to
to defer to actually get the reasons a
reason for refusal
looking through the viability assessment
and potentially getting an additional
opinion
on the viability um to see whether or
not we can back up the members wish
and and thought that actually more
affordable housing can be provided
so that would be our recommendation to
to members
uh thank you ian um councillor keane
coming first
yeah i just wanted to sort of add that
also
maybe what we need to be looking at is
is ways to reduce or find other funding
for the infrastructure needs
i know you've said about the possibility
of the road thing but
can that not be firmed up beforehand
um no we're beholden to the department
of transport unfortunately
with regards to whether or not that
funding is going to be agreed or not so
um unfortunately not
council guys
um just a brief comment um the 10
we have a requirement for 30 um in our
local plan
as what we would ideally like um my
feeling on the
um offers of 10 is that it's actually so
low it was offensive
and 15 percent is still derisory um
and that i just put that out as a
comment
uh thank you for that council garner did
you want to come uh
well yeah okay
i saw council whitehead was wanted to
speak as well but i
i mean i'll come back to the point that
i made i i mean with all due respect to
everybody
who's spoken we've debated this twice
long and hard we've listened to all
all the evidence and we've rejected it
and
so you know we've we've we've said
no to this application and so we should
i think we you know we could go away and
try and get up to 18
or try and persuade us again around some
of the evidence but we've
we've said throw so i think that we we
need to stick
to what we've said we reject it
thank you council ghana before i bring
councillor whitehead in um
announce this uh stealth backing please
thank you chair thank you councillor
ghana we absolutely understand what
you're saying what the committee is
saying
the problem is in planning terms and
when you go to appeal it's not enough to
say no
and it's not enough to say no faced with
our own evidence that supports the
evidence on viability presented by the
applicant
so all ian is suggesting i think is that
perhaps we have
and and you know this has happened
before i think here in other councils as
well where we
we've you know got this situation is
that we have a short deferral
for us to present back to you some
cogent regions for
reasons for refusal that could then back
up your decision to say no
so that that's simply what ian is
recommending so we absolutely understand
that you're saying no
but it's not enough just to say no we
have to have some good evidenced reasons
for that
uh thank you for that uh still i'll
bring in councillor whitehead and then i
think
i will draw a line because i think there
are policy officers here
as i said earlier on are making sense
and i think most of us
all of us have had training for planning
and again i totally understand i keep
saying this
about members of the public and their
feelings um
and yes i do i don't need laughter thank
you um
and there is a process as being said
that we have to follow
otherwise the whole thing will come back
whether we like something or not
i've seen it over the years been on
planning and i know other members have
as well
so i totally appreciate the input
we're all having tonight because it is a
difficult one we must
this council must get get it right
um councilwoman
thank you chair i think the problem is
that it becomes
very circular and going back to the
wider perspective issue
we have to rely on central legislation
in order to make
our secondary legislation and our plans
and so we do that the problem that we
have
is that central legislation often
doesn't suit us as an area
it doesn't fit what we need and then
we're faced with
a circumstance where
we are fully aware within our roles that
we have to evidence our decisions we're
fully aware that we have to be
very very conscious
of each grounds that we're looking at
but the problem is that the central
legislation that we're working from
doesn't allow us to reflect the needs of
our area
and so then councils such as ours
which have significant issues
in terms of finance in terms of land
value
where we already have significantly
deprived demographics
we're effectively asked
to use legislation that we don't think
fits
in order to make decisions that affects
our community
and i extend that to everyone within the
council i have the
utmost respect for plumbing and i have
the administration for officers
and councillors but we are all put in
exceptionally difficult situations by
this arrangement
and then we're faced with a choice of
sending an application back that we know
will have significant financial
repercussions for the council
it isn't that we're unaware of it we are
we are aware of that
and it's something that i've spoken of
before when we've had to
accept reduced um percentages in terms
of affordability
but there comes a point where we have to
say that something within the system
doesn't work
and even if it's nothing that we can
actively change
at a council level it has to be recorded
externally
eventually by the many councils who are
bringing up the same issues within
committees throughout the country
that we are not being served by our
central planning
framework
and it's cases like this that make it
ever clearer that there needs to be a
level of local important and
understanding
to make developments viable
and i don't like being in this position
and i don't like saying this
because i know how hard offices work and
i know how hard planning works
and i know how difficult it is for
counsellors
to decide on these things and i know how
difficult it is to hear
a lot of these things for members of the
public
but we do have to start understanding
why things aren't adding up and why
things aren't working
and sometimes that does mean that you
just have to say
it doesn't work anymore and at the
moment it doesn't work
because it doesn't work for than it
sorry
thank you thank you very much for that
councillor whitehead and again
i'm saying this i totally understand
what you're getting at we we have a very
difficult situation but it's not just
than it i know then it has
some very important parts to playing
things and
decoration and so on fully aware and if
we could change it all tomorrow i know
we all would
but as you know full well it doesn't
work that way
um i think listening to everybody here
that
um as we mentioned that
this comes back and i'm sure i'll be
told
wrong um but we've heard what you've
said tonight
officers have heard i've heard um
to see if anything can be
spoken about um and i'm sure you will
tell me wrong i i'm saying this
um because of the the housing you know
the
15 which you all have concerns with
about the site
i think again we must remember also we
haven't got there in front of us yet but
we're going to have some very very
difficult decisions on this planning
committee in the next
two three years because as you're all
aware there are some
very big sites proposed although we
haven't got them yet
um i'm not saying something to look
forward to again
we do take it all of us very seriously
what's going on
um but i think if
we can bring this back and see if
officers can come back and um
with if i make sense members
i don't think we've had in all my years
and other people shared something quite
quite like this before um but we are
listening to you
so it would be to
the recommendation from officers would
be to defer it to bring it back with
reasons for refusal on lack of
affordable housing
that would be the recommendation at this
point
oh okay thank you for that ian that that
is
i know it's come from the officer but i
think we're all working together here as
i
said earlier on um could i have a
proposal please for uh
yeah good yeah i mean i'm i'm happy
to propose that officers
uh come back to the next committee
meeting
with with the refusal reasons
that the you know the reasons we're
going to be refusing this we are
refusing this application
so they're going to go away and come
back and document
as well as they can reasons for that
refusal based on the discussion we've
had
we had tonight and so
that is then what goes on to the record
so then if the applicant does want to
okay the opera might not want to appeal
if the applicant does then they're
appealing against
the reasons that we've given that the
officers will document
for us to consider a future meeting
that's correct
totally understand what you're saying
council regardless i think
i'm happy to propose that thank you um
you're right um what you're saying there
a bit more detail
we know what we need or what the
committee need and we know
we know what the members of public and
residents are asking for
so the proposal has been made i'd like a
second to please
counselor paul moore on the back members
you've heard
what has been said there do you all
agree
i agree and that is to bring that
this subject back to would it be the
next
in july i know planning is
overwhelmed and we can
i i can try and bring it back next month
yeah so i asked members and again
members of the public who i know
as i say have massive concerns on this
um
please be patient but we will have an
outcome from this
and it will be done what i was going to
say to
council ghana it we all have to do this
correctly otherwise it can't if it
backfires
um the authority
i think you understand that thank you
members on that we haven't finished yet
so we've still got indigen
other agenda items but um i think a five
minute
comfort break thank you for members of
the public for
listening and we'll have a few moments
break
thank you thank you
[Music]
[Music]
and um members of the public who
i believe are part of our couple of
gender items thank you
for holding on uh so moving on to agenda
item
five um schedule a scheduled planning
applications and public speaking
um members will be pleased to know that
there are any site visits planned they
will be
on the 9th of july
so and let's hope
if well if there is a site visit also um
that's when it will take place right
agenda item 5a
is the planning application for approval
uh three the not 20 page road on
westgate um speaking in favor of the
application
is mr richards are you there mr richards
yeah thank you thank you
thank you chair and leader members um
i'd also thank officers for working
collaboratively
collaboratively and positive experience
through the process
this application seeks planning
this application seeks planning
permission for the change of use to
flexible community
use comprising an education facility
medical facility
or the public house and micro brewery
for that to be retained
this means that only one of these uses
at any point could
take place however changing between
those uses would not require formal
planning
planning permission hence it being a
flexible use
the knot would be a community building
finding one of these uses
and as such it would have strong
community benefits
policy cm02 seeks to protect existing
community
community facilities there has been a
lack of interest in take up
of the consensus public house and
microbrewery to date
as such the applicant would like that
not to contribute positively to the
local community
other uses that will be classed as
community uses include a medical
facility
or education facility and these are
proposed in addition to retaining the
public household microbrewery plan
offers
paying officers agree that the scheme
would have benefits particularly
uh in terms of a new medical facility
which is specifically encouraged by
policy sp38
um if this was the one of the if it was
deemed to be used in this way
um it would be a single treatment room
as either a gp or a dentist
in terms of the education facility this
would be a local facility providing
extracurricular lessons for
ages 15 and over perhaps music or unit
course
core subjects all of the proposed users
would have a community benefit and this
has been acknowledged by officers
the site is located in the westgate
conservation area no alterations to the
existing building
proposed and it merely seeks change of
use and the scheme would result in no
impact in terms of the heritage
turn into transport the site is located
in the town
center as a sustainable location the
pros always for a local facility that
will be uh easy easy
to walk to or cycle to this is
particularly the case if it was the
education facility
um and gp surgery and obviously the
public house
um the highway authority have raised no
objection to the proposal and have
confirmed that a
car parking will be provided uh this
will be in the form of two car parking
spaces off street
um while it has been deemed that there
is adequate parked car parking on site
there are public car parks nearby um and
visitors will bite will be directed
from the outset in conclusion the
proposed users are encouraged by
planning policy there is no conflict
with palin
policy in this regard and the scheme
would provide benefit
um as a community facility and
it would make use of a vacant property
at present
thank you
uh thank you very much uh mr richards um
i will now ask the planning officer to
give
the report um i believe he's annabelle
thank you yeah
and this is the application site
outlined in red so this is
not um and it's associated car park
outlined in blue
this is an aerial view of the
application site in the surrounding area
of the knot
in this location here the car park this
is old boundary road
and you can see there's residential
development and after development
in close proximity to the site uh just a
couple of pictures of the knot
and this is an overview of it and the
actual application relates as has been
said to the micro brewery and the micro
pub that are currently
within the knot and they that is in
relation to part of the basement and
ground floor of the building so this is
existing basement plan
and this is a proposed basement plan and
this is the area here at the bottom of
the screen
that would be affected um by the
flexible use and this is where it would
take place
um this is the existing ground floor
plan
and again this is a proposed ground
floor
plan and the flexible use will take
place in this location here
as has been mentioned there are no
external changes proposed
so the building will look the same
externally
so it is the use that members are
considering
excuse me and has as has been outlined
the free uses we're
considering in this proposal for
flexible use
are the public house and micro brewery
so the consented use
at the moment a medical facility and an
educational facility
and the nature of how those flexible
uses has actually been spelt out
and just now by the uh by the speaker so
i won't
go over that again
officers agree that all the proposed
uses are
community functions so the community
function would be retained on site
and it's not considered there's any
adverse impacts on residential amenities
amenities or highways that could not be
required to be
if required be controlled by condition
so the recommendation is for approval
uh thank you annabelle i move that the
officer's recommendation is adopted
could the vice chair please second
i'll second that you i think accounts
for coleman cook
members do i have any speakers
no okay so straight to the vote
um put it to you
do you agree this is uh four offices
recommendation please show
your hands anyone against
abstentions
uh i'm for that one james thank you
that is carried thank you members very
much
and mike on again helps agenda item 5b
uh planning application for deferral um
the land
rear the 4 to number 10 station road
burstington uh speaking in favor of the
application
is a miss coles
thank you very much we have three
minutes thank you
thank you chair good evening i represent
hume planning consultancy in making this
representation to the committee
on behalf of the applicant the site
constitutes to the large part previously
developed land that occupies a highly
sustainable location
within the heart of birchington the site
is located to the river parade of
commercial premises that front to
station road
some of which have residential
apartments above it is proposed to
develop the site to provide a pair of
semi-attached dwellings
that would continue the alignment of an
adjacent terrace of four
flint dwellings known as alma cottages
it should be noted that planning
permission was granted in 2015 the
erection detached two-story dwelling
with on-plot parking within part of the
application site
to where unit 2 is now proposed the
pattern of development within this part
of birchington is strongly characterized
by parallel terraces
of modest two-story dwellings such as
alma cottages and those fronting
westfield road
the proportions alignment and
materiality of the development has been
directly influenced
by this prevailing character the
materials to be used for the development
would be slates flint
panels stock bricks with timber doors
and windows giving a traditional and
characterful appearance to the
development
this is compatible with the heritage
context to the site which includes the
adjacent conservation area
and two listed buildings including the
church the proposal has been supported
by the council's planning and
conservation
offices in these terms the case office's
evaluation of the proposal has confirmed
that it is compatible with neighbouring
buildings and spaces
both in terms of residential amenity of
neighbouring residents and for future
residents of the development
both dwellings benefit from fronts and
rear gardens
access to the site is gained via a
private drive leading between 10 and 12
station road
that currently provides vehicular access
to a number of existing residential
properties and commercial units
notwithstanding the grants of the 2015
permission for dwelling with on-block
parking
in light of comments from kcc highways
on-plot parking
for the development has been removed
from the proposal and in accordance with
their recommendation is now presented as
car free housing
suitable for a site within a central
location such as this
existing parking that lies outside of
the site serving existing properties
will remain
in all cases statutory consultees have
raised no objection and technical
matters are addressed through condition
the applicant is provided signed
unilateral undertaking securing the
contribution towards the council's sam's
tariff
within these terms and further to the
office's positive recommendation
it is respectfully requested that member
support is given to the application
which represents a sustainable form of
residential development that accords
with the provision of the mppf
and the adoptive development plan thank
you chair
uh thank you miss coles uh speaking
three and raising
points of concern and misread
[Music]
thank you
apologies members
is over kvu members i think i did see
miss brim there
earlier
did you want some chips while she's down
it's becoming a long evening members i
don't know if there's in football
but i'm interested in that but uh i will
move on to
the officer's report uh is that
annabelle please
thank you
excuse me thank you chair
and this is the application site
outlined in red
so we have station road running across
the top of the slide
here um this is a
saint all saints parish church sorry and
we have the public house here
and as has been mentioned the church
is a great is a listed building grade
two i think sorry um this is a
aerial view of the site so the site sits
in here
the church is just off of your uh the
slide here but you can see some of the
graveyard around it
and this is station road here
so this is some photographs of the site
so we have the access
into the site here that coming off
station road
these are alma cottages that have been
referred to it's the terrace of four
cottages and this is number four and
this is number one
and this is a flank wall of number four
and
that you can see and there are no
windows at first forever when that flank
elevation
and you can see beyond that fence at the
front of that
um elevation would is part of the
application site
this is the application site and looking
back towards the rear of the properties
in station road
as has been mentioned the majority of
those properties are commercial at
ground floor level
but there is some residential
development above
those properties and this is the
application site and you can see the spy
of the church behind
and there are some buildings on the site
that would be
removed to make way for the advocate for
the proposed development
and this is actually standing in the
churchyard as you can see by the
tomb on the right there and again
looking back to the application sites
you can see the properties and station
road beyond the rear of them
and that is the flank wall number four
all the costumes
so as can be seen here this is the
applications
access to the application site this is
the proposed layout of the
semi-detached properties
and this is the front elevation of the
properties and
it's been mentioned that materials are
traditional in nature so slates
flint detailing stock bricks and timber
doors and windows
and officers do consider the the design
of the properties and the materials
proposed
to be appropriate for this location so
just looking at the upper renovations we
have the southeast elevation which is
a flank elevation of the proposed
dwellings
and this is the rear elevation and the
other side elevation
um looking at the ground floor
of the proposed dwellings you can see
they
do not mirror each other but they are
very similar they
each have a projecting element to them
they are open plan kitchen living dining
room
in each property and looking at the
first floor you'll see their free beds
with a family bathroom
and that's the roof plan of the site so
the dwellings are do meet the required
technical space standards for new
developments
and would be served by both front and
rear gardens
and it is considered they would provide
a good standard of a residential amenity
for future occupiers
and it's not considered there would be
any adverse impact on the residential
amenities of existing occupants
there is some 11 meters to the closest
part of the
of the rear of the properties facing
onto station road
but that is actually to the single-story
um
rear commercial sorry grand commercial
elements of those properties
and the actual upper floors are set
further in from
the rear and the closest um
upper floor element would be some 18
meters away from the proposed new
development as has been shown from the
photographs there is no first floor
window in the flank wall of number four
alma cottages and there would be no
first floor window also in that flank
and the flank elevation of number unit 2
that is being proposed there
so it's not considered to be any
overlooking or adverse effect on
residential amenity
as has been mentioned the properties
will not be served by car parking
but this is not considered necessary
given the
very sustainable location of the site
so the um offices that are
can consider the scheme to be acceptable
to not have an adverse impact on
character appearance residential and
menacing
and provide a good standard of
accommodation for future occupiers
and there will be no adverse impact in
terms of highway safety or parking
within the area
so the application is recommended for
deferral back to officers to secure the
sound contribution via the union
undertaking thank you
thank you annabelle if members
can understand uh miss brim disappeared
for a moment there but she's here this
evening
so i will allow her to speak uh with her
concerns
mr him thank you chair sorry i apologize
for my absence um
this evening i'm speaking on behalf of
all of the residents of alma cottages
and some
in the surrounding areas the cottages
were built in 1840 and sit within the
conservation area
and over time the rural setting has
become urbanized with continual
development
the only rural setting remaining which
also gives winter sunlight
is the covenanted land facing the grade
two listed all
saints church and its surrounding trees
the proposed development would certainly
destroy this last urban
section which has existed for 180 years
and
impact the cartilage to the listed
building
a contentious point of concern regarding
this application is the legal ownership
of the private track
connecting station road to alma cottages
this track was laid in 1840 to give
access only to the cottages
and until fairly recently remain solely
for this purpose
over time a few nearby business owners
have removed the original boundary walls
without planning consent
thus giving them illegal vehicle access
to the rear
of their properties this was opposed by
the cottages but they continued to
illegally use the track
and now claim they have use of this due
to adverse
possession the residents feel that the
development would further the misuse of
their private track
and question the legality of passing
on access to a new development gained
through adverse circumstances which
heaps harm
upon harm and is not equitable
part three of the constitution
determines applications made under the
1990
town and country planning act and states
that the authority has the ability to
exercise enforcement functions
on the grounds of safety can you ensure
that you will be exercising your
enforcement powers if the no car rule is
flouted
as the act also states that no
application should be made
to the detriment of others the kcc
highways report clearly states that the
private road is detrimental
to road users and pedestrian safety
this also brings into question
protection to the residents if the
proposed development misused the area
to gain vehicle access as part section 6
section 143 of the 1988 road traffic
act states that a person must not use a
motor vehicle on a road unless there is
a force
in relation to the use of the vehicle by
that person
such a policy of insurance or such a
security in respect of third-party risks
as complies with the requirement of this
part of the act
this brings into question whether a
policy of insurance is valid in a
proposed area
that has been deemed a car-free zone by
the authority
and this application is potentially
prejudicial
to the rights or the in of interested
parties objecting
on the grounds of health safety and
disability and the residents would like
to
request a site visit thank you uh
thank you miss brim
thank you for that as well james um
i move the officer's recommendation is
adopted uh
vice chair please second or second that
members do you wish to debate at all
council right mr chairman um i actually
do agree that we
i think the committee would benefit from
a site visit
i do as one of the world councillors for
for virgins and south um i do feel that
it
this development will be detrimental to
the conservation area
cramped and overbearing um
parking i'm not quite sure where the
office of
thinks the park any cars will be parked
parking in birchington and i think there
are two other
cap councillors here from virgins and
will agree parking is at a premium
premium in birchington and there is
nowhere for it
for any other car extra cars to park
thank you
thank you that's the right to i see any
other members wish to speak
councillor zesky yeah thank you chair i
agree with councillor right
a site visit is essential thank you
councillor keane thank you chair
i just wanted to ask annabelle about the
views on
on the vehicular access can't say it
um that the room has raised
thank you are you okay i'll try and come
back yes
it is not proposed as we've seen that
the cop other
proposed dwellings will have car parking
spaces so it is unlikely
in their own right that they may well be
attracting vehicular access coming
through
and the kaiwei comments are
set out in the report um whether or not
there are caveats or
legal restrictions on the use of that
vehicular access
is not something that we consider as a
planning matter is a civil matter
but if there were you know that would be
a matter to be dealt with by local
residents
and the developer if it came to that um
it is a sustainable location
um obviously close to a church public
house and many other facilities that
this site
surrounding area offers so it it is not
considered necessary by officers that
these houses
should have um car parking and it is
considered there are
public car parks and various um other
areas that parking
could take place obviously it might be
some distance potentially in
but look within walking distance of
these properties
should future occupiers choose to have a
car
thank you annabelle look out some more
paul moore yes thank you chair um
however you say that there is no
requirement for parking
but you did sound the drawings that it's
got front guard and rear gardens
could those front guns then
inadvertently
have vehicles parked on them once
they're developed and if so
would it be a condition of planning that
there is no parking on those front lawns
thank you
annabelle
there are some permitted development
rights that do allow
the creation of vehicular accesses to
front gardens
um i don't unfortunately have the report
in front of me to
apologize i don't know if it is
conditioned but if members fought it
necessary that could be conditioned that
that permitted development right is
taken away in this instance
sorry we're just checking what the
report actually says
okay i'll come to council fellows yeah
thank you sure i mean
just uh go back to the parking and to
say that um
that they can park within walking
distance shows there's complete a lack
of knowledge of parking in birchington
i mean these look like two family homes
which could possibly be four cars
i mean they're just there was just there
was just no parking with within walking
distance inversion
it is chock-a-block it's all resident
permits and and limited parking
that is one hour parking bays or home
birches and all around the area and
and dubbing the line so to say there's
parking within walking distance
you're then going to be burdening other
people's parking
thank you uh council fellows um
ian have you found um
thank you chair um so that there is a
there's a specific highways condition
which relates actually to condition
surveys for
during construction um but there's no
restriction on removing permitted
development rights for
um effectively creation of hard standing
on
the front garden now there is a
condition which relates to
the actual plans that have been
submitted so there is a condition which
would restrict the development deviating
from that
but as it stands there isn't the ability
there isn't
the removal of permitted development
rights to create heart standing so
members if they considered necessary
would be able to impose that condition
to avoid
in the future an owner creating a car
parking space
which could potentially lead to use of
an access which obviously has mentioned
there are concerns about in terms of
visibility etc
but obviously it there is the opposing
view i know that obviously
that there's being discussed about
whether or not parking is actually
needed
for these units because obviously of
what potentially
could happen with regards to
displacement of existing parking
i think just come back to that point it
is a
a very sustainable location um and
i appreciate that the concerns that
members of of continued raised is that
actually people will want to have cars
and obviously we had this with the
addington place application
um you know a month or so ago um but it
is obviously something that wouldn't
result in
the highways view and also in our view
on a severe impact on the network
for two units requiring parking in and
around the area
um in our view thanks chad uh thank you
ian
any other speakers at all council ghana
thank you yeah i'd just like to ask
about the um
i know there are six trees in relation
to the site
five of them not actually on the site
but very close
and one on the site which i understand
is um
has been rather unsympathetically pruned
in the words of the um
biodiversity officer and i assume he's
going to be lost
in as a result of this um so i'm just
seeking
assurances that the other five trees
aren't going to have their root
protection area
affected by any of this development
and also i saw that i see there's a
condition for a soft and hard
landscaping plan
um to be to be um
prepared and presented before any
and delivered before any occupation can
you tell me sort of
how are there going to be new new
what new planting you're expecting on
the site as a result of that
and i know i've been i've been in touch
with um
with enforcement on a number of other
developments in my ward where soft and
hard landscaping plans
have been as a condition and then not
delivered so
i know you can't assure me at this
meeting that um
this soft landscaping plan would be
delivered before any occupation
but i'm just raising that as a concern i
have that
we pass these conditions but then we
don't make sure that they're delivered
so i'm i am sort of seeking some
assurance on that
thank you so thank you uh
council ghana don't worry cancer
whitehead i thought we had a new member
of the council sitting at the back there
so
annabelle did you want to come back on
that door
yeah sorry chair there is a plan
actually
here that actually details the soft
landscaping
um here i think the condition is
to draw on this plan and build upon it
and to give more detailing as you say on
actual sort of boundary treatments
and things like that as well as but we
wouldn't necessarily
normally require for a couple of
dwellings
the details of precise planting because
they are someone's
effectively effective garden so it would
be
a fairly generic planting proposed
landscaping scene that would expect to
come forward rather than
you know just to ensure that there is
planting and it isn't a bare sight
but not you know ridiculously
high levels of detail but if it wasn't
to come forward
we could secure that and look to force
against
you know the non submission
of the plan good sorry if i could
just come back as long as if if it's if
it's
the landscaping if it's green i it's not
going to be hard
concrete over it then that's certainly
etc because i've seen
others where it said it was going to be
green and there's not one bit of green
on the site at
all so that's what i'm i'm seeking to
ensure assurance
that and that would help with the um car
parking as well
make sure it's garden instead of
concrete
thank you council ghana council pullman
oh sorry carry on sorry thank you
and looking at all the photographs and
the maps and everything else
um to use a very technical term it looks
like um they're trying to squidge in
two rather large buildings into a
relatively small space
whose own vista is not going to be um
that wonderful looking out on
on the backs of some other properties or
whatever
and i would certainly support what was
said earlier about at least having a
site visit
thank you sorry sorry i missed you there
can support more
yes thank you chair just to uh reaffirm
what council ghana was saying that
if the permitted development rights were
removed for any hard standing
then it would always be a greenfield
area on that area thank you
thank you um no other speakers i'll make
sure
yes you can yes
so rather than whispering the chairs
here i'll i'll make it so that everyone
can hear it
um no no no not not telling off at all
um members have already raised the issue
about
um removing pd rights a few of you have
mentioned about removing pdrs because
of this particular concern um i think on
that basis
that if the chair and vice chair as
proposer and secondary would agree
then we could amend the motions before
members
if both parties agreed to include a
condition which would specifically
remove permitted development rights
under class f of the gpdo schedule 2
part a
part 1 part 1 that would then basically
take away the ability for someone
to um to put a hard surface down
without needing planning permission so
they could still apply for planning
permission for it but they can do it
without
that being considered by this council so
if that was
agreeable do you understand that council
vice chairman i understood yeah
thank you very much would agree and
members agree yeah yeah just
two of us okay any other speakers at all
right i've got to put this to you
um for recommendation
to defer or for approval
um i know a site visit to mention but
we'll come to that in a moment
those in favor for deferral
please show
those against
abstentions
right no it's not no can we
do that again please i know it's getting
late but
i've got a bit i think i've got those in
favor those
those in favor
this is not for a site visit this is for
approval
of the deferring two officers
are you included in that as well yes
okay those against
no abstentions
that's been carried yes thank you thank
you that has been carried there members
thank you um that concludes the public
speaking for this evening
uh i will now ask james
to read out those uh plan applications
i come to you know cancer ghana um
[Music]
that's what i was trying to explain to
you there you voted
you abstained yes
[Music]
the officer's recommendation was to
approve
on if that motion gets voted down it
moves to the next motion
which could be proposal for a site visit
obviously the majority of the committee
voted to approve the motion that was on
the table
majority of people in favour
it's clear enough on the paperwork what
we were asking what i ask you
to vote for and it's
in front of you as well members the
officer's recommendation
is to defer for approval and that's what
i have to ask you to start with
you showed your hands and those were in
favor
sure
miss brim please uh you're not in the
council now
um i would have come back
if that motion had been lost
and then put it to members again for a
site visit
i just want to say that we've all been
trained in plane we know the rules yes
i'm sorry i i can't i can't accept that
people didn't know what they were voting
for
no i mean that's how you know i looked i
know
james counts the numbers here
and the numbers you saw we had eight in
favor
so that's more than abstained
um we had six extensions so it's not
enough to make a difference anyway
i'm sorry but you know
again it is on our reports in front of
us hell
voting should go oh but um
okay go back to the conclusion of public
speaking
uh i will call upon james if you would
for those
items on the agenda that haven't been
called
james thank you chair so the remaining
items haven't been called then
is 5b which is ellington park ramsgate
5c 60 northumberland avenue 5d
croquet lawns the royal esplanade and 5e
which is 14
st john's avenue thank you james does
anybody wish to speak on any of those
items
i don't see any hands going up so
therefore could i have a proposal
that those applications are
moved proposal please
there's two council rzesky
seconder so little hands up there take
your pick james
uh do members agree
thank you members apologies for that
misunderstanding there but
say it is uh like i've got you know it
is in front of us so
so therefore the public i'll ask james
just to go through those
applications once again and then we will
call him into
the meeting okay thank you
so the um those applications were
ellington park ramsgate
60 northumberland avenue margate croquet
lawns royal esplanade
ramsgate and 14 st john's avenue
landscape
thank you thank you members that
concludes
this evening's meeting thank you for
your attendance
and take care safe journey home